Hello Android Developer Program engine is not in favor today
When designing a drowsy app, the most basic sk independent pixels
We want to talk about dp.
The first thing you should think about before designing an app
There are a variety of opportunities in the world and the fact that there are Android devices in shape
Also the pixel density of the vise may be different
Inflorescence density is determined by the number of points in a 1-inch square
In other words, it is expressed as a multiply-in value dpi, and generally this bpi value
Indicate how clearly the image or text on the screen is rendered.
It becomes an indicator
One example is how the English dictation is based on different dpi values
Let's look at the clutches.
As you can see, if you have a higher pixel density value like 452 ti
After the letter e is much higher than the other screen with lower dpi
It is clean and accurate.
The Android devices are here as well as various synthetic fibers like 165 234
You can find something to bring
If you're a developer, and you want to respond to all of these values,
It can be troublesome.
So do not come in to make your life more comfortable,
We classify the 9-minute control devices into a virtual logical Mars 1 degree unit
There is
Some typical pixel density units used in Android include:
The same
For example, for a device with 165 dpi,
Will be classified
So you do not have to think about the number 165 anymore
Actually, the 2 van 6 dpi is a special number.
On Android, the baseline city area standard is called the "
I explained that everything, including the dicer parser dip,
It is based on the value of rice cake.
At present, when Android 80 160 dpi and more than this type 1
240 320 480 dpi All four Mars are also most widely priced
Is being used
In addition to this, you can use ldpi or 13 dpi values ​​with a 120 dpi value
Although the tv dpi you have is expressed, it is rarely used
You do not have to worry about your current
Now that I've found out about Synthetic Text, I'm in the Android design.
I will explain the core density density wave 3 and 4
Density Diversity Pasteur Besti Independent pixels are generally shortened to dp or
I'm talking about dip.
It's a sort of virtual inflorescence. At 160 dpi,
Actually, one pixel is exactly represented by one d pixel, and more
For example, if the density is high, x hdpe
, One pixel of the dete tp is enlarged by 2 times in the vertical direction,
Can be represented as real pixels
So why on Android do you use this dp design?
The biggest reason is that the Android app's iRayas design and user
When designing an interface, each a ui element has a different pixel density
Make it physically similar on your device
Because I wanted to
Let's look at an example here: 200 across two different devices
dp height is elongated purple squares
I have an mdpi screen for a tablet device, and on this device
The 200 pp value will be accurately represented as 200p cells
Again, 1 dp is exactly one pixel at the reference density
Is expressed
On the other hand, the Lexus smartphone here has xhdpi power.
200 dp height is represented by 400 pixels on the second foot
Will
Because this conversion is done automatically on Android platform cars
Developers do not have to worry too much
One interesting thing to note here is that using dp units
Even though the screen density changes, the actual physical size remains similar
You can also use this dp unit to indicate the size of the actual object
There is
For example, the size of a finger on a person can be expressed in roughly 50 tp
When you design a button like this, you can see this value
You can avoid mistakes such as designing buttons that are too small for hard work.
There is
Next you need to set the depth value so that you can freely
Let's take a look at how to calculate
You do not have to worry too much about the formula
It's the only thing you need to know.
As you can see, if you know the three values ​​that are not yet defined
One other value is known
Let's take a look at her.
The definition of dp is as follows:
2, 1 dp is exactly 1 pixel, and the cell is exactly 1 dp
is
Many screen densities are xhdpi, that is, 302 dpi is doubled
When talked pa size becomes this pixel
So let's use this news to solve a more real problem.
The latest Lexus SEVEN device screens launched in 2013 in depth resolution units
How much would it be expressed in terms of
We know the following information: Screen size is 7 inches 9 screen
The density is shown in xhdpi and 320 dpi.
The screen resolution is 1920 x 1200 pixels
Which of these heights would you use to calculate the dp resolution?
In fact, the size of the actual physical screen is 7 inches.
not
You need to know the actual screen size of the device when you want to find independent pixel values.
There is not
As described in the first paragraph, xhdpi and the reference density of the original density
mdpi The simple ratio is two days, and I recall the formula I saw earlier.
In this case, to convert the pixel value to dp, simply use the pixel value
Divide by 2
So the correct answer is to divide 120 by 2,
The 960 is the 600d P of the bar
So what does this transformation already do?
In general, the dp impression is smaller than the pixel resolution,
I can see that it's better representation of size
For example, a 1280 file with 800 pixels large mdpi tablet device
1280 files 720 pixels wide Think xhdpi mobile phone
There is
The pixel resolution of two devices is almost similar, but the actual screen size is
Will be much smaller if
If you change the dp value to a decent value,
720 dp impression, while mobile phone has 306 cdp
You will have as expected
This is almost twice the size of the actual device's physical screen size.
You can think of it as a better reflector
In terms of security, it is related to dp and also supports virtualization soda
There is
The scale is an Independent 3 or s game
s & p is the font size setting you need on your system,
If the size is set to Medium, dp will match exactly
Therefore, it is useful to use it when assigning it to the text of the app pair
Finally, when you design your Android ui,
I will.
First, you should always use dp units when designing ui
If you use the dp value to represent the size or position of the ui element,
It will be much easier to create an app that works properly in House
Will
In order to express the second image clearly,
You must provide a different graphics 1 source
For example, here's a share icon, where Work 2 is defined as 32 dp
Therefore, in order to cope with each screen density without auto scaling,
You need to prepare png file in addition to 4 kinds of porridge.
Finally, to make it easier for you to use your x,
Please use sp unit when setting text size
It's really important to design an Android app so far.
Has been explained about
To design applications that work well on various screen sizes
There are a lot of people who are suffering.
Visit the Android developer site, especially the design for multi-screen page
Find a lot of useful information, including about the dp we discussed today.
can
Please take a look at it.